[Music]
you had your previous special bear you
talk for 14 minutes on that special
about gun control over them and now
people really like what you said and
that segment goes viral every time
there's under incident which seems like
every week now do you feel what do you
feel like what you said connected so
much I just said some common-sense
things but people like now get so angry
at me about the gun thing I get hate
mail all the time and to the extent that
it's worse for me when there's a
massacre overseas like what happened in
nice obviously was horrible and I'm type
of stuff but the gun nuts as soon as
that happened in nice they all wrote to
me because I'm the only gun guy and they
go well maybe we knew truck control and
I'm like we already have it you got to
get a license you got a register the
truck I can't get a truck I don't have a
truck license yeah okay drive one this
is the thing about gun control people
can go on and on if we have a little bit
of gun control then they'll take our
guns America you already have gun
control you already have it we're just
asking for a little bit more like
terrorists can't buy guns just simple
things like you
you already you already have things in
place like you can't put a bayonet on
the end of your gun because that would
make a gun too scary and the right to
bear arms for some reason that's just
about guns but it extends to ok in Texas
you can open carry a gun you can have a
sniper rifle which is not a protection
gun in any way no one's ever sat in
their front yard looking through a thing
looking at something for miles away and
thought if this guy keeps coming towards
my family
you can open carry a machine gun in
target but you can't open carry a
chainsaw that would be ridiculous you
can't walk into target with your
chainsaw and go this is more protection
chainsaw this chainsaw to protect me and
my family the only way to stop a bad guy
with a chainsaw is a good guy with a
chainsaw
[Applause]
ooh boy
[Laughter]
you